and basically i'm just gonna
do essentially what we did
with the
handheld version just
now that it's on the robot
today we are looking at the frontier
device it has an embedded computer a
multi-camera system a lidar and inside
there is hidden an inertial measurement
unit
the cameras work
pretty much as our eyes
the lidar basically allows you to get a
point cloud of the environment by firing
lasers at the environment and by
measuring the return time it can get you
a metric measurement of what's around
you
and the imu works pretty much as our
internal ear it gives us
an idea of where gravity is and how fast
we are rotating all of these sensors can
be fused together to
answer the main question in robotics
called
slum simultaneous localization and
mapping so the localization bit is
knowing where you are and mapping is
what's around you islam is pretty much
like a chicken egg problem
you don't know where you are you want to
know where you are in the environment
but at the same time you also want to
know
how the environment looks like if you
walk around
you're going to see
an orange line that shows where we were
before
so if i keep walking around
and i come back to the same place i was
before
i can show you the main ingredient of
slum which is loop closure there you go
so here
you see a red line
this red line means that the system who
recorded all our previous position
recognize if we were back to the same
place
and in this way we can correct all of
the errors we have accumulated this far
and have a better map by adjusting it
knowing that we were there before the
screen was just to quick visualization
but all of the problem is being solved
in 3d
so here is the exact same problem we
have sold before so here you see the
table we see all of the map in 3d being
built
and the loop closure is right here so
after
just a very quick walk we have a
complete 3d map of the environment and
we also have our past trajectory the map
is mainly built using the lidar because
it gives you a continuous stream of
point clouds
but to accurately know where we were
uh we also need to fuse the imu because
there is physics inside so the army
tells us your acceleration for instance
so mu is
inertial measurement unit yes if for
instance there is an error of
registration between two point clouds
and we don't use the imu
the system i just think we teleported
somewhere else but the army is telling
us no your acceleration was like that so
your velocity should have been like that
and you should be here instead of
somewhere else so if you use the imu on
its own it'd be kind of dead reckoning
it would be guessing yes
yes so there is a component of that
draconian but this is fused together
with the other sensors so if you were
doing that dragon all of the time then
we would
end up on the moon because there are
many smaller errors that gets integrated
over time
so the imu is just giving us an idea of
where we should be between two camera
images or between two lidar
uh point clouds
and then the measurement from the point
clouds and the cameras
kind of correct those
and are merged together so we can have a
walk and go downstairs in the lab
so we unofficially call it the bath lab
and the reason for that is because we
have a huge elevator
that can
carry an entire car
here we are going to show the quadruped
section of our lab
what's funny is the camera can see some
of the lidar yeah
yes because it's um
it's near infrared and camera don't have
infrared filters
there you go so here we have different
quadrupeds today we're gonna see the
spot one this is all the way from where
we were before here with the
the round table the loop closures and we
went downstairs so all of the
compensation is inside here but for ease
of visualization we have some interfaces
on the phone and on the computer
most of our software is compatible with
ros which is a framework that is widely
used in robotics community there are
many libraries and programs ready to use
to accelerate robotics
this one in particular is called
roseboard and
it's running a little server on the
computer
and on the other side there is a client
that gets the outputs from our
algorithms as
messages and these messages are then
relayed and visualized in the
in in the web page web browser interface
so on the phone that's just basically
running yeah i mean the phone is yeah
it's just
an optional that we
we use especially when we do handheld
missions we want to have an immediate
feedback of what's going on everything
is going all right so we have developed
this interface slam is very useful for
robotics in particular because
it allows us obviously to know
where the robot is and what the map
around it looks like so
um i'm just going to drive around the
lab a little bit
and then we'll be able to see kind of uh
what the lab looks like
[Music]
and
now that we're
kind of done
again you can see we have a map of the
environment we have a loop closure
and
slam is essentially a key component in
enabling
robot autonomy so a lot of the work that
we're doing in
kind of remote inspection mission
planning all of those kind of things
relies on
the ability of the robot to know
where it is and the structure of the map
to actually do useful things um
you know nuclear decommissioning those
kind of things is what we're
um looking at the handheld has its uses
but also if
we can do this with a robot obviously we
don't have to send people into the same
places sometimes
it's easier to access places with humans
so the handheld device is useful but
other times we prefer to use a robot so
we have both options
this is the one we saw in bristol yes on
the front we've got what we call a
frontier device it's running the exact
same mapping software but we're just not
running the autonomy part of the system
right now what i'm going to show is the
algorithm that is running inside the
frontier
and the main technique that is using it
which is called factor graph
so a factor graph is a way to solve
this islam problem uh by modeling the
unknowns as nodes so we might have
uh
our position x1 and then position x2
position x3
and so on
and
this is what we want to know in addition
to
landmarks which are basically points in
the environment which eventually will
make up our map so we can think of the
landmark says
l1 l2 l3 and so on
and the measurements that come from
camera or imu or any other sensor create
a relationship between these unknowns
the imu might just tell us okay so
between x1 and x2 your position should
have incremented by this amount because
your acceleration was this much over
this period therefore velocity and
therefore position
and at the same time you can have you
know multiple imei measurements so
you connect this
and
from x1 you might just see also things
from the camera features in the
environment for instance a corner
that you can track over time so this
creates also some other relationships
between our position and the landmark
and
you can see the same landmarks over
different times
so you can create these sort of
relationships
and if you keep adding all of these
constraints
then you have a strong idea of where you
should have been and what was around you
because all of these relationships are
merged into an optimization problem
where the unknowns are exactly x1 x2 x3
and l1 l2 l3
and in this way the algorithm will find
the best solution that
makes sense or all of this relationship
together
and then the last bit comes to solve the
islam problem
imagine that we we walked a very very
long way so imagine i've made this chain
very long and at some point we are at
time x 50 and
in reality we should be in x2 because we
have kept track of all of the
measurement we have collected so far and
so we have a map of them
and we
close the loop by thinking okay i'm
exactly in the same place as x2 so i can
create a relationship between
x2 and x50
in this way all of the error we have
accumulated up to x50 gets corrected the
map gets warped to
match reality
and we have solved the islam problem
it's oversimplified if i say islam
problem is solved many many professors
will become angry yeah you have solved
some problem in this specific situation
yes you did but not generally solved no
yeah so in practice is yet not solved
because there are many problems related
to
noise in the sensors and
inaccuracy in the calibration so
there are techniques to
make this uh solution more robust for
instance so
if you have islam system working
then you know where you are and what's
around you and also robots don't know
where they are and what's around them so
we can make do autonomous things
jane street is a research driven trading
firm with offices in new york hong kong
and london full of impossibly creative
and clever people they like to think the
next star individuals that may be
working for them could be watching this
computer file video right now that's why
they're hoping you might peruse their
website including this section for
internships are these the sorts of jobs
that might launch your career check out
jane street there's a link in the video
description and our thanks to them for
supporting this episode of computer file
you